key ingredient is the purple one these
wooden blocks which has like a wet
pepper star anis that infuses the fish
you don't need it unlike anything that's
Anthony Bourdain dining with Chef James
see a boat in Laos on an episode of his
popular show parts unknown see aboot
fled Laos when his family with his
family when he was young after it fell
to communist 1975 they arrived in
Oakland six years later beginning SIA
boots journey from refugee to culinary
rock star he is the force behind the two
Michelin star restaurants call me and
its sister eatery hawker fare which
focuses on the Lao and cuisine of his
childhood
chef SIA boots new book is called hawker
fare stories and recipes from a refugee
and chef asanas Thai and Lao routes in
the preface Bourdain writes that SIA
boot has quote done more than any other
person in the world to get the word out
about this unfairly unnecessarily secret
country and cuisine hawker fare is
published by Bourdain's book imprint
Anthony Bourdain and James SIA boot join
us at the table good morning
why is Lao cuisine still a secret
Anthony well I mean I think we've been
eating a lot of la cuisine but in Thai
restaurants so much of the Thai food we
love is in fact ethnic Laotian coming
from the asan region so we're familiar
with at least the general outline of a
lot of those flavors and a lot of those
dishes and chances are already deeply
love them but but for the real deal
there's more to it besides they're two
common dishes a flop and papaya salad
that you see in Thai restaurants that is
you know culturally Lau James you write
in this book and there's this great
little intros to in the beating all
about your country and about you and
your family which I think are just so
rich with history and you write just
like the US campaign to drop an S load
of bombs on Laos during the Vietnam War
was called the secret war Laos is kind
of the secret country what are some of
the most well known or favorite dishes
in Laos what I think bamboo shoot'
they don't see commonly in Thai
restaurants even so of like you know
cooked in a lot of our bases and bitter
flavors there you're not accustomed to
in Lao food and I'm in Thai food I'm
here at the serving restaurants so you
know the spice levels the preservation
of losing you know fermented fish sauce
no that's not that's unfiltered you know
it's not the clear for Sashi you
typically see on the supermarket shelves
and that's where the flavor bombs are
not what makes Lao food really separate
and different from your common Thai food
as we know what happened when you first
tried common Thai food what was that
experience like - first come first kind
of type of I was my parent my mom my
mother's restaurant again and growing up
was restaurant kid and it was like what
we cooked for ourselves and what we
severed during the menu it's like this
is what Americans live for was the
distance between the two fairly far yeah
not not even a resemblance what I think
it's so interesting is that you describe
this book as an apology of sorts to your
parents you said you were embarrassed
and ashamed that you abandon your roots
of lao cooking and then then you went to
culinary school to focus on fine dining
and then you realize hey my roots are ok
talk about that process for you I
thought that was very interesting yeah
so because of Lao food and Thai food
that's how I got interested in cooking
you know I kind of dropped the sideline
it to go to fine dining because I can
see a future career wise in law cuisine
and took the cup in you know worked all
the Michelin star restaurants I can in
the world and you know it was a hidden
point where it's like you know I need to
pay homage to how I got started right
and it's kind of shame and didn't know
how to cook this food I grew up on you
know Anthony food is also about
hospitality
and you write that the lotion people are
some of the most food crazy generous
most hospitable people you've ever met
and you've traveled the world to look
this is deeply richly satisfying food
with deep interesting flavors
interestingly increasingly the kind of
flavors that that fine-dining chefs
crave after work you know spice and funk
spice and yes like to eat funk yeah you
know I like yogi you know that the first
that the flavor fermentation but for me
what you know what's exciting about this
book and and and so many of the really
great cookbooks and chef stories is that
story of cultural identity you know
who's the history of the world is one
chef told me is in this plate it's
telling a story often a very personal
one a very old story so to me this is
very much a book about what it means to
be American who's cooking in America now
what is American food all these things
that we value and care about a story of
a you know struggle to find or reconnect
with ethnic and cultural identity these
are really relevant questions given
current times well this is one of the
best best endorsements you can have for
a book Anthony Bourdain says this book
will make you a better person before you
even try a recipe I could cook I'd make
something for the Soul tell me is right
nice to see you
yeah Anthony always good to have you at
the table q Anthony Bourdain and James
Tsui booth we thank you again hawker
fare by the way goes on sale next
Tuesday wherever you like to buy your
books you got lots of choices